I'd say you know if you are a patriot
you want to be part of a grateful nation
when you are gonna meet that veteran and
invite him into your home have a place
to point them to what do you guys make
of our alliances and the way they really
sort of shifted over the last five years
let's say and just what's going on with
NATO and the United Nations I mean Trump
is basically obliterated the United
Nations NATO is shifting and that more
than that that if we don't do anything
nobody does anything and that that is
the sort of bargain that the United
States in that's that's very difficult
do you think that's a fair thing to say
if we don't do anything internationally
no one does anything what NATO sure sure
it isn't I mean uh I mean the UN has you
know proven to be I think exposed at
this point as they will end us and so
yeah I mean America has had to step up
and fill the gap but I think also the
president is a kind of exposed that that
we everyone needs to come to the table
one and contribute and you know he's
really he's really I called them out
that day the UN summit I think it was a
UN summit where he really exposed them
on this and so yeah but I do believe
that there's American does have
responsibility to fill the gap I don't
believe we're in a nation-building and
and handle ever brought me to be a
firefighter for every fire in the world
but I do believe we have a
responsibility as a strongest nation in
the world yeah why don't other countries
step up it doesn't seem like anyone
stepped up anymore like they all say
they like to hate us and then they ask
us for help and then sometimes we
overstepped the line and now that gets
worse I mean there's this crazy bargain
always happening because we've been that
security blanket for them for so long
you know my first tour duty was over in
Europe and you know I was part of a NATO
unit and when you looked at you know the
other airborne units were part at NATO
you just kind of scratch your head like
you know dudes what are y'all doing
y'all even train I mean you can't hit
the you know the broadside of a barn you
know but these collective body politics
United Nations European Union I think
they're being rejected and now when you
look at the security organizations like
NATO President Trump was going in and
said hey guys
whiskey-tango-foxtrot when he called out
Angela Merkel for having a deal with
Russia for natural gas and now
you're asking me to protect you from
Russia but you're doing economic deals
with Russia come on
does that make sense and furthermore
you're not owning up to your 2%
responsibility of financing and NATO I
will tell you when I was in Afghanistan
the biggest problem for the German army
was obesity because they were just send
out you know good sausage and bread and
everything they weren't getting out they
weren't fighting anyone in southern
Afghanistan we had the Brits we had the
Canadians we had the Romanians and we
had the Dutch and they each had a
separate province and each of them had
their own rules of engagement or you
know orders from the Ministry of Defense
they didn't coordinate within each other
and so the Taliban would just easily
understood what we can do this and in
this problem is because the Dutch are
not going to drop bombs on us they're
just gonna fly over our heads and you
know be real loud so at that point NATO
doesn't have a have a standard operating
procedure now we're all doing something
to other base upon their respective
ministries of the defence everyone knew
that the Romanians the orders for the
Romanians they could not lead the roads
they could not get out of their vehicles
Wow
so I mean how you gonna win against an
enemy when you have your Ministry of
Defence dictating all of these different
you know is that changing under NATO now
well I haven't been back to Afghanistan
since 2008 or 7 so I wouldn't know but I
think that you know maybe when you look
at the Georgia's we're going out and
doing patrols maybe it is different but
these major NATO member countries
they're not stepping up and I would even
begin to question why we have Turkey and
NATO because Iran is not a friend to
Western civilization but other countries
are stepping up because of what you said
I mean as the u.s. comes back and moves
to that support and advisory capacity
then they have to they have to do their
part I mean this is a strong
presidential administration saying that
hey you guys gonna do your role we're
not gonna go out there and do all these
combat person terrible American wars do
all these combat patrols why you sit
back on a base this is a strategy and
shift of the military and the
administration yeah you see a big surge
in a special operations community and
that support an advisory role too so
let's let's shift to veterans because I
think that that's what brings you guys
really together I think how did you guys
meet by the way was it
was it through the nonprofit how did you
meet how do we meet I think you needed
some army friends yeah call me up now
we're in the same circles of people and
we have mutual friends and we both have
a very I mean absolute both Patriots and
level warriors and and after outside a
uniform we're both still serving and we
you know kinder kinder heart and hearts
to do this mission yeah
so you started mighty mighty okay can
you tell us a little bit about that and
and colonel s sits on the board yeah
maybe it's it's it's hard to tell you
without Jerry aluminum my story you know
after my eighth deployment to
Afghanistan I was diagnosed with
post-traumatic stress disorder to give
you a kind of how that started for me it
started with a you know just coming home
and being frustrated angry I have a wife
and three I've been married for 24 years
and three amazing children and and they
really enjoyed me coming home and just
being a tyrant to them you know lots of
verbal abuse and never physical abuse
but throwing things breaking things is
acting like a lunatic around my house
did you know something was wrong with
you where were you aware of it enough I
was I tell you when at first like I was
that anger intensity worked really well
in Afghanistan like I said that Afghans
I worked with they hated the Taliban the
task force I was on was a kind of biking
kind of war culture mindset and so it
worked really well Afghanistan but 24
hours later when I'd be home wife and
children I didn't work well there I
couldn't like flip a switch and turn it
off so I recognized that but it was a
moment that I came home from my from
Afghanistan I made it home for my
daughter's birthday she was so excited I
was gonna be there and I remember uh
she's very opinionated and she still is
and she didn't like the icing on her
cake and just saying that like I flipped
out and I grabbed my little girl's
birthday cake and picked it up and threw
it against the wall well destroy my
little daughter's birthday and I
remember in that moment thinking like
what kind of person doesn't looking at
dad does something like that and and
that was one example but at that moment
I realized that to just back off instead
of fixing the behavior I just kind of
distance myself and so between these
eight deployments I would just stay busy
at schools and training and work ups and
just stayed busy and isolated myself
from them and over time that anger
started turning anxiety I started having
these uh physiological symptoms my arms
go numb my face for going on I feel like
my throat was swelling shut sometimes I
feel like I had like a thousand pounds
on my chest and I started researching
what the this was and I learned was
panic attacks and but I didn't want to
say anything that the guys have worked
with and it's a little special special
operations group I figured the guys
would think I was weak maybe I'll lose
my clearance and so I didn't I didn't
speak up I tried to push it down and do
my job and eventually those symptoms got
much worse I actually started having
these moments where I almost felt like a
detached like out of body experience I
wake up by these fogs and realize I
didn't remember the last few weeks and
so I had to speak up and say something
cuz I wasn't only put myself in danger
but I was putting other people in danger
as well and so that's when I was brought
home and I was diagnosed with
post-traumatic stress disorder and that
began that wasn't my rock-bottom but I
began a very downward spiral in my life
my wife and my psychologists and we're
trying to help me move forward and I was
in such a state of the only way I really
know how to describe like the state of
panic that I was in I just recently kind
of came up with words for it it's like
if you were like ankle was handcuffed to
the bottom of a pool drain and yeah I
got like the surface was about a foot
above your head and you had just how
desperate you would be for one breath of
air but you never drowned you never die
like that's how I was like 24/7 and on
top of that panic I felt totally ashamed
because I was so proud of the job I was
doing and my whole identity was wrapped
in that job and now what's gone and so
my wife and my counselor we're trying to
find something for me to do and that's
where the MMA and jujitsu came in I'd
say that it since I was little but I'm
still a little yeah since I was five
years old and Wow
and so I was already professional
fighters so I dove into that and just
invested my time in that and had a great
new a success and to being 18 and 2 as a
pro fighter I won a world title belt
Legacy FC and formed Strikeforce and all
these shows but really what I did was I
never got well I found something to hide
in like somebody went climbing a bottle
alcohol or drugs for me that's where I
just just made myself occupied and so
eventually do you think that's where
most people are at when they start
getting into MMA because as you know
obviously yeah absolutely blowing up and
and Joe Rogan's talking all the fighters
all the time and there really seems to
be this this thing about getting your
[ __ ] together that that seems to be the
beginning point
what's a dispatch style yeah be
discipline like everything around I'm
competing I was telling my less
he's like you still compete I'm
competing Jitsu turn that's doing the
world's World Championships in August
and the reason why is because it helps
me regimen my life like it's something I
put a date on the calendar and
everything in my life becomes discipline
the way my family life is the way I eat
the way I sleep it brings him read the
way I manage my schedule for traveling
and speaking everything becomes reg a
minute so I try to compete like twice a
year for that when you live in the
lifestyle of a professional fighter and
competing at that very high level like I
competed that it really helped me manage
my life and my life was I was still
dealing panic attacks I was still angry
I was still my life was still kind of in
disarray and my marriage really began to
deteriorate because I wasn't addressing
the problem and so eventually I ended up
in an affair I didn't care me my wife I
was so callous at that point and some
what we set our kids down and said we
were getting divorced and I my wife
filed for divorce we sold our home moved
into separate apartments like sign
12-month leases and my wife and I had
two very different reactions and my wife
went into a church and I don't mean like
on a Sunday she went like every day got
connected with a group of people and she
said she started praying for me and at
that time I was praying as far away from
God if she could possibly be him and but
I asked her now of course what was she
praying for me at this time it should
just pray God let me see Chad the way
you see Chad let me love Chad the way
you love Chad let me forgive Chad that
we you forgave Chad and so yeah this
woman that's like fighting for me
meanwhile I'm in his apartment
immediately like I'm separated from this
woman I don't have to deal with anymore
I don't be responsible for that the
problems always causing anymore and so I
had a big fight on Showtime Strikeforce
and and that's what I was focused on and
when that fight was over end up winning
that fight but as I won that fight in a
Toyota centers like ten thousand people
there I remember thinking oh my hand was
raised like my wife wasn't there and
she'd always be my cheerleader before
mhm
something about that I went back to my
apartment that night and I started
thinking about all the problems that
call us the people I hurt my family
mainly and I thought well I blamed
everyone else before like I was a common
denominator like it was the problem with
me and when I came to the start I this
idea came over me that somehow my family
would be sad without me but they would
be better off now if you know anything
about the veteran suicide rate that same
hopeless thought finds a home in the
hearts of
Plus veterans every day that not I'm
gonna kill myself just get my pain but
you know somehow you think that people
around me be sad my family would be sad
my friends will be sad but they're gonna
be better off and so that decision
really seemed like it made sense to me
and I made a decision to take my life
I'd uh in that apartment I had all my
family pictures I'm ashamed to say but
it's true I and all my family pictures
in my closet because you know girls
coming over why not
and so I I would sit in my closet with
my I shut the door and I put my family
pictures on the floor and I try to build
them the courage I put the pistol to my
aunt a Glock 22 pistol I put it to my my
head I put it in my mouth trying to
build up the courage and I don't know
what to this day I've had the courage to
actually pull the trigger because I
didn't but what did keep me from doing
it was my son Hunter the one that's in
Afghanistan right now he had done the
key to my apartment and I knew he'd be
the one he defined me or opened the door
for someone to find me and that kept me
from actually doing it
one morning I called my wife she says
that call she said I was frantic I don't
really remember the call but she came to
my apartment and when she came I was
actually in the closet with that pistol
and and she knocked on my door and
unwittingly you know intervened and
saved my life I remember hiding that
pistol under my blanket well I wanted to
find it and she answered the door and we
got this confrontation and she asked me
a question that ever radically changed
my life she asked me how I could do
everything I did in the Marine Corps she
saw me become a recon marine let me
train for these deployments and all
these things in Afghanistan and trained
for MMA fights cutting weight and all
the discipline it takes to do that she's
like how could you do all of that and
when it comes to your family you'll quit
and that question for me would be called
a quitter which is one of those soul
cutting words to me it just impacted me
and you had to make a change so Wow all
right there's a lot there so well first
off thank you for being so upfront about
the personal stuff because I know that's
not easy for anybody so before we get to
mighty oaks then I'm sure you have heard
many many stories that are like that did
you ever experience anything along those
lines did you ever go down that path no
me personally you know I it was just
different for me I have a very
supportive wife who her dad was career
military also did 24 years in the Army
in Vietnam two tours and he's buried at
Arlington National Cemetery so we always
tried to have that very strong support
and as a battalion commander I remember
when before we went to Iraq you know I
tried to tell the soldiers that the
person that you are here when you put
your first step on those stairs to go
into that airplane you gotta leave that
person here and the person that you are
over there somehow you've got to leave
that person over there and I think that
that's what the struggle is for our
warriors to be able to to make that
switch it's not saying that you're
you're cold and callous to be able to do
it but you just understand what's
required of you you know your nation is
calling you to be a certain person but
your family is also causing you calling
you to be a certain person and and
that's what veterans and that's what our
military men and women are struggling
with because we put them in these very
intense combat situations and then we
extricate them from them and we put them
back into the family and I don't think
we do a really good job of the
decompression time over there before
they come back home I think that you
need a good two to three weeks before
you know as you're coming out of those
combat zones of operation before you
come home and it's important that they
talk to each other we don't we don't
allow that do do we do none of that I
mean they're well we travel across the
world take some time but you you mean
some like real time I mean over there
and and you know instead of rushing we
got to get them back home you know we
got to get all the equipment loaded I'm
getting back home take the time a couple
of weeks to just let guys sit around and
talk and and get that opportunity to
leave that person over there and start
mentally preparing themselves to go back
because a lot has changed and your
families you've been gone you know your
wife your kids they've continued on with
their lives you you're kind of the one
that's coming back in then you're kind
of the guest yeah and you've got to you
know you know real cussing yourself it's
got to be a huge catch-22 though because
in their minds they're all going I want
to get home tomorrow
yes get Mol
yeah but I think that in the long run it
would be so beneficial you know I
remember I did a year in Korea in 1995
and my daughter my oldest daughter when
I left nothing she was a little over a
year and you know that was the day
before Skype and everything like that
oh you sharing VHS tapes and
what-have-you but when I got back from
Korea you know she was there and she
looked at me said like I think I know
who you are who you are and so it was
all about redeveloping that relationship
you know taking her out you know
daddy-daughter time just just whatever
and then finally she realized okay this
is a guy I've been seeing you know on
those videotapes yeah he's my dad he's
not leaving he's not going anywhere
so I think it's important that we allow
our guys to have that time but we are
putting them as such a constant
deployment cycle and that's why I get so
upset about how we have reduced the the
strength of our military because we're
running these warriors we're running
their families into the ground and
that's why mighty oaks is so important
yeah so you handed me the Segway talk
talk to me about why you started mighty
oaks well in that in that reaction of a
wife's question you know why would I not
fight for my my family and my own life I
had to respond to that and I and through
that response I found this solution that
many of our space not just me
we we I knew I couldn't make those
changes by myself and you needed help
and so I asked my wife was there someone
in this church she was going to because
I because I knew I couldn't do it with
the people around me as well I had some
great friends but there were more people
had telling me what I wanted to hear not
what I needed to hear and so I made a
man named Steve Toth and Steve is a
Texas State Legislature now and at the
time he was the elder at church more my
wife was going to in a small business
owner and we met at a Starbucks coffee
shop in him and I had a perfect plan of
how I was gonna fix my life and it was
really I was probably slid it over to
him really smug he put his hand on it
slid it right back over to me and told
me I was gonna fail and I remember being
like really really offended cuz I'm like
it's pretty good and really what I was
trying to do is manipulate him to say
take this plan show it to my wife
because I'm trying to fix things mm-hmm
and he tapped on that paper and he said
if this thing doesn't have anything to
do with your relationship with God I'm
not gonna waste your time and that glad
you waste mine and I know a lot of
people may not agree
with with my favorite Thor what I
believe but I'll tell you this I tried
everything and tried I've been through
the I've been through all the consoling
all the programs had been on the pills
and I tried professional success I'd
been successful financially and and my
career is athlete and as an instructor I
had a thousand students in my school and
I was teaching and so I had I tried all
those things and nothing that worked and
so it's time for me to try something
different we have a saying at mighty
oaks if what you're doing isn't working
then why not try something different and
so I trusted this man Steve I surrender
my life to God through his leadership
and his mentorship and things in my life
start to radically change I I found a
restoration hope for a first time I hope
in a very long time and I found
ultimately what I'm what I've been
searching for the whole time all life
and that's purpose and that purpose was
to share what I discovered with other
people and that was somebody else began
through that process I learned something
really important that it sounds so
simple but to me it's it was so profound
that all these things that happened to
me my childhood Afghanistan losing one
of the best friends foster parent and we
served together for 10 years when he was
killed and on our first deployments all
these things that had happened to me
didn't leave me to be in a closet with
my pistol man would let me they were the
choices I made response to those things
and I still had control of that I still
had that control the Billy choose
differently and as cliche as it may
sound I didn't have to let my past to
find my future I could she was a
different future moving forward and in
doing that part of that future I chose
moving forward was to take what I
discovered and share with others it was
like if I was dying of cancer and this
guy Steve gave me the cure I had to
share it I felt obligated to share it
and so that's how we started mighty oaks
we went ready at the time my wife and I
were still bleeding as a family trying
to heal but we both felt passionate to
do this from this mission and I'm so
thankful we did I mean to date I've
spoken to over a hundred thousand active
duty troops and bases around the world
my request to share message on it was
resiliency I go to Marine Corps boot
camp the Marine Corps allows me to speak
at Marine Corps boot camp these young
warriors about resiliency and spiritual
resiliency and we run a program program
called a legacy program it's our
recovery program we have four ranches in
a California Ohio Virginia and Texas and
we pay for everything
travel flights
all the program is totally free
active-duty veterans and spouses come
these programs we do 30 camps per year
and we've had 2,600 graduates from those
from those camps and so it's been been
absolutely incredible and it take what
the lessons I've learned and realized
that I wasn't the only one I wasn't
alone
22 veterans everyday were taking their
lives at the same time I was going
through this divorce rates and some
bases are up to 80% for combat veterans
like a lot of people having the same
issues I had I had the solution and now
and now we we had the most amazing team
people like Kona West Ono board and a
general Boykin and we have a soldier
major Marine Corps sergeant major Ken
who's a great friend of both of ours out
shot us both about one shot yeah we we I
just have the most amazing team and
staff to serve these warriors we have a
I think 14 full time staff members and
about 40 instructors that are all combat
veterans that it serve as instructors at
these programs yes absolutely incredible
there's so much there so it's really
interesting to me that you said you
tried everything else and and faith is
what works for you now I assume that as
a man of faith you hear something like
that and that doesn't surprise you no it
doesn't it absolutely doesn't and and I
think that you know in the Bible it says
that you can do all things through
Christ Jesus who strengthens you and
that's the message we need to get out
there you and I were talking earlier
about you know the victim mentality and
I always tell people you got two choices
in life you be a victim or you be a
Victoire and that's why I hate
Progressive Socialist because it tells
people that are going to be victims and
that's not what America is about
and even more so Dave when you look at
what is happening with our young people
in United States of America right now
the suicide rate it's because they're
searching for something and and they're
out there trying everything they're on
the internet they're on the social media
they plan the videogames they they want
to be cool the drugs and everything that
the world says that you can have to to
make you accept it but there's just one
thing that can really feel that
emptiness in your heart and I think you
know we talked about an awakening in
this country I also see a faith
awakening in this country as well yeah
it's interesting I you guys probably
know I've been on tour with Jordan
Peters in for the last year and a half
or so
you know he's not trying to sell a
religion on anyone particularly but he
is trying to show the power of religious
stories and meaning the meaning and all
of the things that I think you're
talking about and I do see a rebirth of
that and it's been I've actually seen it
all over the world because we've
traveled all over the world and it's
pretty fascinating to see firsthand
because it's not what the media shows
you and you know he's more Z on this you
can't be around that for a year year and
a half and not be moved personally out
of that well that's one of the things
you know leftism is about secular
humanism because they don't want you to
believe that you can have faith and hope
and something other than the government
and when you look at what you know our
founders created when you look and read
John Locke's Second Treatise own
government natural rights theory your
inalienable rights are not dictated to
you by man it comes from a creator life
flavor they can take them from you but
they came from but they didn't give them
to you and that's the thing that we have
to come to understand and that's why you
see this dry to move you know faith out
of the the mainstream in the United
States of America because they don't
want people to understand that you know
I don't have to wait for you to give it
to me okay it's already been given to me
you know I have the ability to pursue my
happiness Bernie Sanders Kamala Harris
Spartacus all you guys you guys can't
you know you can't guarantee happiness
for me and I think that's what Chad is
saying he went to all of these other
things to try to fill that hole in his
life and then Steve Toth told him that
here here's the answer I got the
Spartacus reference there I mean as
there is hope on this because those
people that are coming to us 1/2 of
those people in active duty military
orders coming being sent from the
military they don't agree with the fact
that we're a faith-based program but
they're looking for solutions
if 15 years ago the DoD and VA began
just pushing clinical programs we've had
we have a 1100 VA and DOD clinical
programs at the time the suicide rate
was 16 today it's only gotten worse and
and so there the military the VA the
veteran community are looking for
answers
and faith-based programs like mighty
oaks have to have proven to be
successful we just finished finished a
three-year longitude data a doctoral
study and I can bore you with the
numbers from it but we did outperform
clinical trials in this independent
study I assume there are some secular
organizations that are doing very
similar things that probably have decent
success rates - you're just saying that
for for you and for people that are
like-minded that this works for you but
you don't have any inherent problem with
people doing it from a more no executive
respect I don't I do be I do believe
that a some of those some of those
things are gonna be short-lived
when people go and inspired or motivated
inspiration motivation tend to fade
sustained faith faith and faith in a God
that greatest tends to sustain and it
gives you a resiliency to bounce back so
I do believe that personally but however
I've seen some other great great
programs out there I just believe that
that when you when people make the
decision to align their lives with the
lives that we were created to live they
find true resiliency and true strength
and real hope and real purpose with my
Borg and we've seen that firsthand and
thousands of guys and not everyone that
comes to a program or matter-of-fact
about half of the people that come
they'll program would say they share our
faith when they come but you're looking
for something that they hadn't found
anywhere else so this hour absolutely
flew by so if I was giving you guys each
a closing statement here how is it that
you'd want that average person out there
to get involved help help some of these
wounded warriors help help you guys get
the mission out there I think we did a
little of it yeah yeah a little of it
here but but what would you want people
to do I think it's the most important
thing is just don't go up to say thank
you for your service get to know a
veteran they're veterans we should not
have homeless and jobless veterans in
the United States of America and and if
you know a veteran that is out there
alone environment to your home show them
the real love that the love that they
extend it to you that they were going to
lay down their life for your freedom
it's gonna be tough to beat that one I'd
say you know if you are a patriot you
want to be part of a grateful nation
when you are gonna meet that veteran and
invite him into your home I have a place
to point them to and as plenty of places
out there mighty oaks
foundation is a place that they can
point people to as a resource to help
our warriors that are struggling with
suicide
divorce PTSD all those all those issues
and we not only a resource but a free
one would cover all the costs to that so
free tool that your disposal has a
grateful nation is servo warriors any
warriors listening our spouses just you
know visit our website and again we'll
take care of you and the website is
mighty oaks programs org that's right
yeah all right it's been a pleasure guys
thanks mom thank you so much and I
should tell you considering five years
ago I thought you were a complete nut
bag I don't know I don't know if this
says now more about you about you know
what that's the thing you know you have
to stand strong and eventually light
will overcome now you ended the show
twice on her on a solid notarized with
everybody
[Music]